ما المعلومات المتوفره حتى اللحظه بشان
هذه الضربات الجديده ايض وتؤكد مصادر ان
ما استهدف هو في قاعده الديلمي بمطار
صنعاء وكانت هذا هذا
الهدف الهجوم البريطاني الامريكيه هذه
الليله حسب مصادر تابعه لجماعه الانصار
الله ياتي والذي ياتي بعد عمليات البارحه
لم يسمع بعد هذه الانفجار بعد الانفجار
الس الذي سمع في صنعاء و سمعته ايضا انا
وانا في مناطق شرقيه
لصنعاء سمعت ذلك
الانفجار ايضا بعد ذلك لم يسمع اي انفجار
او استهداف اخر حتى اللحظه وتاتي هذه
العمليه بعد اعلان التحالف الثنائي
البريطاني الامريكي اكتفائه البارحه
باستهداف 16 موقعا تابع لقوات صنعاء في
عدد من المدن اليمنيه واستئناف هذه
العمليه مره اخرى هذه الليله يثير تساؤلات
هل اصبحت المدن التي تقع تحت سيطره جماعه
انصاره في مرمى عمليات انتقائيه من حين
لاخر حتى تصل الى قناعه انها قضت على ما
تصفه القدرات التي تهددها في البحر الاحمر
وياتي هذا التصعيد ايضا في الوقت الذي
يواجه انصار الله عمليات كانت تشن بشكل
شبه يومي على مناطق مماث مماثله ل لذات
الهدف من قبل التحالف ويؤكد انصار ان
المقاتلات البريطانيه والامريكيه كانت
مساهمه في تلك العمليات الذي شنت لمده تسع
سنوات وان الجماعه رغم تلك العمليات باتت
اقوى من اي وقت سابق وبقدرات عسكريه فهذه
المصادر تشكك ايضا انه حتى وان شنت عمليات
اخرى فانها لن تنال من قدرات جماعه انصار
الله فيما تؤكد يؤكد مراقبون انه من
الافضل الاستماع الى المطالب او الشط التي
مفادها ان يفتح ويرفع الحصار على غزه
ويسمح بدخول الدواء والغذاء بدلا من
التصعيد و والذي قد يؤدي الى مهالك
اكبر وتوسع الصراع في
المنطقه ا طيب ماذا نفهم من تصريحاتك
التتي جءت على لسان حزام الاسد اذا او
حزام الاسد عضو المكتب السياسي لانصار
للحوثيين التي يقول فيها فلتكن حرب مفتوحه
مثل ما تريدها او واشنطن ما الذي يمكن ان
نتكهن به
هنا هذا حسب ما ما تحدثت سابقا انه هناك
مخاوف لان استمرار الصراع و وعدم اكتفاء
العمليات البريطانيه الامريكيه ب بهدف او
موقع او موقعين او ثلاثه بل واستمرار هذه
العمليات كانت بدايتها في البحر الاحمر
منع السفن ثم توسعت اشتباكات مباشره بين
قوات جماعه انصار الله وال القوات
الامريكيه
الان دخول مرحله جديده وهي ضربات وغرا
جويه وضربات صاروخيه وجويه فقد ما ما يشير
اليه الاسد انه ستكون حرب مفتوحه ما يعني
ان كما هدد اليوم المجلس السياسيه الاعلى
التابع لجماعه انصار الله بان المصالح
البريطانيه والامريكيه ستص تصبح اهداف
اصبحت اهداف مشروعه لجماعه انصار الله
خصوصا المصالح المت الموجوده في المنطقه
فنحن نشهد من فينه لاخرى توسع الصراع وكل
ومن مره الاخرى كل طرف يعلن اهداف جديده
وبنوك اهداف جديده هذا ما يشير الى ان
الصراع ذاهب الى التوسع وهو ما يشكل خطر
حتى على الملاحه في البحر الاحمر والذي
يخاف طرفي الصراع بان يصل الى هذا الحد